[Applaudissements]
ça se voit fabrice on a dit qu'on ferait
comme ça je sais mais ça se voit ça se
voir un accord a changé ma pompe
s'il te plaît faites merci on est
emmerdé
on est emmerdé parce que on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait exactement le
problème du sujet dont on est venu vous
parler c'est ballot moi je m'appelle
accès de la tua da et en ce moment je
suis auteur et comédien moi je m'appelle
fabrice de bonis et en ce moment je suis
auteur et réalisateur
moi je sais pas ce que je fous là en
fait je crois que tu es un imposteur
mais non c'est à dire que la plupart du
temps je me dis que de toute façon il ya
forcément quelqu'un quelque part qui est
beaucoup plus intéressante mois et qui
devrait être à ma place et moi moi je
crois que je vais vomir
parce que là au moment où je vous parle
je suis extrêmement mal à l'aise parce
qu'en fait le truc c'est que j'ai la
croyance que quand on me filme en fête
est belle je suis je suis toujours moche
à l'écran oui donc bat comme un rat
comme un bon réalisateur m'a je me cache
toujours derrière les caméras vraiment
ce qui vous dit pas c'est qu'il est
aussi coach spécialisé en neurosciences
appliquée et il le dit pas parce qu'il
croit que s'il vous dit ça mike rann ça
vous arrive à vous de croire des trucs à
la con comme ça qui vous rendent
malheureux en fait ce qu'il veut vous
demandez c'est c'est quand la dernière
fois de votre vie que vous avez renoncé
à quelque chose en vous trouvant comme
bonnes raisons une phrase du genre non
non non non moi je suis comme ça parce
que en fait franchement j'ai posé une
question est ce que vous trouvez ça
pertinent de croire dans votre vie des
choses avec lesquelles vous n'êtes pas
d'accord déjà et qui ensuite deux ça on
vous empêcher de faire ce que vous
voulez et si vous savez c'est toutes les
phrases qui commence par non mais non
mais toute façon je suis trop vieux pour
faire ça non à votre façon j'ai pas le
temps de faire ça dans la même façon
j'ai pas assez confiance en son nom mais
moi je peux pas faire un teddy que parce
que je suis moche à la caméra non mais
de façon moi je peux pas faire de tedx
parce que je suis pas intéressant c'est
ok liste
voyez tout ça ça s'appelle des croyances
pour ceux qui prennent des notes ces
cris ces aides aux il l'annonçait bronze
et savent comment ça s'écrit donc une
croyance en fait c'est pour résumer
c'est toutes les pensées c'est toutes
les opinions vous avez dans la tête et
que vous considérez comme étant la
vérité et au bout d'un an dans toutes
ses pensées et bah on va finir par
croire qu'elle devienne notre identité
moi par exemple je suis pas photogénique
ce c'est à cause de la répartition est
faite de mots visages sur la tête non
mais il ya des gens dans la salle qui
croient comme fabrice qu'ils sont moches
à la caméra tout ça est que sont pas
photogénique des gens ont pas eu la main
oui
ah ah bah tiens par exemple modèle
tu veux dire avec nous sur la scène deux
minutes on n'est pas méchants allait
bien comment ton prénom l'applaudir
karine karine shadrake fabrice matheu
mettre debout là bas comment tu
t'appelles tu peux vous dire ce que
kalyna j'aurais dû prendre quatre
[Musique]
alors est ce que quelqu'un peut me dire
en quoi car karine et jolie c'est facile
pourtant le sourire et boucles
l'aptitude super dire les yeux
pétillants elle est gracieuse elle
souriante
ouais moi je la trouve vulnérables je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
non non non mais attendez attendez parce
que ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
moi personnellement je trouve ça rare je
ne sais pas si c'est pour vous mais
c'est rare quelqu'un qui montre sa
vulnérabilité comme ça ça demande du
courage en fait
ok moi ça me fait quelque chose quand je
vois les gens comme ça qui se mettre en
scène qui montrent leur vulnérabilité
moi je trouve ça beau lors de mon point
de vue bas en ce moment où je retrouve
extrêmement jolie en fait vous centrez
continue est ce que tu veux qu'on
continue sont 400 ils sont 450 du temps
ouais ok bombay qui sont vains s'arrêter
là parce que c'est un peu trop long il à
400 personnes
merci on l'applaudît en fait ce qu'il
faut comprendre le secret écoutez bien
c'est que le cerveau il est un peu con
parce qu'en fait plus vous croyez
quelque chose et plus votre cerveau il
va aller chercher dans la réalité des
détails qui va isoler comme ça et qu'il
va mettre bout à bout pour vous faire
croire que ce que vous croyez
c'est la vérité en fait un de ces taf au
cerveau c'est de confirmer nos croyances
exactement par exemple lors ce moment
vos pensées consciente
elles ont une vitesse de 2008 secondes
c'est comme si vous aviez à peu près
2000 informations qui passent c'est ça
qui passaient chaque seconde dans votre
tête contrée pour bas et au même moment
je vous parle vos pensées inconsciente
elles ont une vitesse de 400 milliards
de bits à la seconde à laisser conter
donc vous vous rendez bien compte en
fait ce que vous pensez consciente c'est
à dire tout ce qu'il contient en fait
vos croyances passé qu'une toute petite
sélection de la réalité tiens merci donc
à force de croire les mêmes choses en
boucle on fait les mêmes trucs à force
de faire les mêmes trucs avait on
obtient il est même résultat et comme on
obtient les mêmes résultats
elle et on renforce nos croyances de
base a compété une assiette vite que toi
je te le dis moi j'suis maladroit as
comme ça comme ça alors pourquoi on
flippe
quand on a peur de changer nos croyances
voulu rester maladroite ou de votre vie
en face à lille et en fait on se dit que
si on change nos croyances
verma perdre notre identité et la
confusion c'est de penser que notre
identité elle repose sur nos croyances
notre identité elle repousse sur nos
valeurs alors qu'est ce que c'est une
valeur
il va alors c'est pourquoi je fais
quelque chose
par exemple en ce moment dans votre
villa je reste à voir quelque chose
qu'est ce qui vous motive vraiment dans
votre villa maintenant en ce moment
c'est quoi c'est l'amour c'est la
liberté
je sais pas la sécurité la joie la
beauté le plaisir la volupté tout ça
c'est des valeurs et ce qui est magique
c'est que toutes ces valeurs dont on
vous parle moi vous et tous les gens de
la planète
on partage tous les mêmes tout son cap
donc pour ce faire cette identité qu'est
ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on va prendre
toutes ces valeurs et puis on va faire
une espèce de hiérarchie on va faire un
top ten à ses malheurs chaque scène est
là où une valeur c'est pourquoi je fais
les choses
une croyance c'est juste comment je fais
ok une croyance c'est juste une manière
d'exprimer vos valeurs c'est des
stratégies en fait par exemple il ya
plein de façons différentes d'exprimer
l'amour je peux choisir d'être libertin
ou d'être exclusive
d'être mariées ou d'être pacsé ou de
devenir curé donné mon amour à dieu il
ya plein de façons d'exprimer la liberté
aussi on peut imaginer quelqu'un dire
oui alors moi en ce moment où je
travaille pas comme ça j'ai tout mon
temps et puis va je suis libre je peux
faire ce que je veux bah moi je
travaille beaucoup
moi j'ai plein d'argent comme ça je fais
ce que je veux et donc je suis libre
vous voyez des fois vous avez la même
valeur que quelqu'un et vous mettez sur
la tranche parce que vous avez des
croyances opposé c'est pas clair mais
avec le geste on comprend pas maintenant
parce que moi j'ai un super exemple pour
qu'elles soient chrétiens donc je vous
explique on est un super exemple c'est
comme un exemple mais avec une cape
ok donc à tintin c'est bon c'est bon
c'est l'histoire de robin des bois
auquel robin des bois sa croyance c'est
qu'il faut voler aux riches pour donner
aux pauvres
mais sa valeur basse et la justice on
est d'accord c'est pour ça qu'il fait ça
le shérif de nottingham son adversaire
lui sa croyance qu'il faut protéger des
riches de robin des bois
et là encore une fois sa valeur c'est
quoi c'est la justice on voyait bien que
ces deux personnages et se tapent dessus
parce qu'ils ont des croyances
complètement opposées alors qu'ils ont
exactement les mêmes valeurs d'un autre
exemple quand on fait la guerre par
exemple j'ai pas faire musique de guerre
ukulélistes ça c'est une croyance par
exemple ouais donc ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que si vous avez
développé une croyance mais c'est qu'à
un moment donné dans votre vie elle vous
a aidé servi à quelque chose
mais comme vous évoluer tout au long de
votre vie cette croyance qui vous a aidé
un moment donné dans votre vie un autre
moment dans un autre contexte
eh ben elle peut devenir limitantes
c'est à dire qu'elle va devenir un
obstacle en fait pour votre évolution et
à partir de là bas c'est un peu comme si
vous décidiez de passer votre vie en
conduisant avec un frein à main bonne
idée
la bonne nouvelle donc c'est que vos
croyances elle vous appartiennent donc
vous comprenez bien que si vos croyances
elles viennent de vous c'est que vous
êtes responsable de ce que vous croyez
et que donc vous pouvez choisir vos
croyances
est-ce que c'est clair pour tout le
monde parce que c'est pas clair non là
je trompé c'est là bas donc vous
comprenez la boxe je vois que ce soit
car parce que si jamais il ya encore des
gens qui ont des doutes sur ce qu'on est
en train de vous raconter on vous a
ramené des preuves
regardez moi ça fait dizaine de minutes
que je que je suis sur la scène d'un pbx
devant 400 personnes personnes s'est
endormi après de rien donc bah c'est
peut-être que je suis assez intéressant
est que je suis à ma place en fait moi
ça fait exactement le même temps que
c'est sur cette scène est a priori le
caméraman n'a pas vomi il sépare ont fui
il n'a pas effacé la carte mémoire
donc c'est bien la preuve que bah je
suis filmé à bhl en la preuve c'est que
je suis filmé ce qu'on veut vous dire en
fait c'est que comme on avait envie
d'être ici et de partager ça avec vous
il ya bien fallu qu'on se met à croire
des trucs qu'elle est nous aider à le
faire en fait donc moi je décide là
maintenant devant vous avec vous grâce à
vous aussi de croire que je suis
légitime et que je fais ma place et
parce que ma place c'est moi qui les
choisit donc je suis forcément légitime
en fait j'ai
et moi moi j'ai choisi de croire que en
fait la beauté bas ça dépend du regard
qu'on pose sur les choses en fait c'est
pas les choses en elle-même qui sont
belles on est d'accord c'est la face on
les regarde et qui les rend belle et ce
qui est fou c'est qu'en fait pour croire
tout ça bah on n'a pas eu du tout à
remettre en question nos identités
c'est à dire nos valeurs qui sont
l'humour la créativité l'amitié et le
partage
alors maintenant avant de terminer ce
taux courts tlx et avant éventuellement
vos applaudissements
on voudrait juste que vous repartiez
avec une question et vous vous la posez
sincèrement et cette question c'est
est-ce que ce que vous croyez de vous
même
ça vous rend heureux tous les jours même
le mardi merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]